5 is already disqualified You can leave the rest to the medical team,
but at 6 o'clock, the video is
up  Are you going to do it?
Go quickly.Is
it okay if I'm disqualified?
Don't try to move right away You can't
make it in time for a good masala Your
skin will be impressed I won't give up until the end
That's the same thing with me
ah ah tai
[music] That's
it
Carp's good
ana
isinstalled
I think it's good to be like o- I think it's good Ah
,
everyone's attention I
'll announce the collector
me
Kurobane Tsubaki
Late Taketori
Koji Yamanaka
Akimitsu Major
Raimoto
Izu Wasabi Iidomiya de Enda
March Uchiha Salad In
addition to the above investigations  I
sent him a Ujina-scale corporal.It's just
a
comprehensive judgment.I
can't always complete my mission perfectly.I can't
let a guy who's going to kill a friend who surfaced in Sadakichi as a
matchmaker.
Let's give evil and say Cheek
, if it's all right, well, if you want to do this, why
don't you say it to everyone? par